[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George camel and I'm
joined by the one the only my smart
money happy hour co-host Rachel Cruz
good to be here George always is we
usually don't host a whole bunch
together but this is when we get to it's
a real treat it's a special time youall
are here for it so uh we haven't got to
hang out in a while Rachel we're taking
calls from people all over the world now
we're we've gone International
officially so if you want to join us
call
8825 5225 we'll answer your questions
we'll give you our best advice sometimes
it we've been known to hurt feelings
we've been known to tell people to sell
the horse this is the kind of stuff that
happens on this show
you're in there a part of the you're an
accomplice Rachel I will give you advice
in a kind nice way George you never know
you never know well congrats Rachel on
your new kids book it's been fun I'm
glad for what I have I read it to Mia
the other day my little she doesn't know
she's 5 months old but she enjoyed it
it's good hey reading even to the young
ones I've heard that George yeah I saw
my wife sent me the Instagram reel thank
you Jonathan is up first in Raleigh
North Carolina Jonathan welcome to the
show hey thanks having me guys
absolutely how can we
help so I am uh long time familiar with
Dave Ramsey um just kind of started
getting into it more recently the last
year um but I am going i' I've done the
baby steps have been debt-free and then
got married and other things so recently
I've done the attempt to get my wife to
budget with me so I got her to watch the
financial pie that was gifted to me cuz
I'm a
veteran um and I got her to watch the
first episode and as soon as I brought
up the fudget she shut it down she was
mad
H yeah so I'm not sure if it's something
more deep-seated going on but we're not
really financially hurting but we are
losing a lot of money just to waste sure
okay so Jonathan why why was she why was
she mad what was what was she saying in
her
anger uh that she didn't want to have
any constraints she didn't want me
control her spending I think she didn't
really want me to know what she was
spending on
okay do you guys budgets do you guys
share an accounts together we do and
that was a point of contention about 13
years ago when we got married but we did
join the accounts and I eliminated her
um she had um college debt and you know
other car loans and and credit cards and
all that and so yeah we've purged all
that since um and joined accounts she
with that getting out of debt yes okay
so it's the budgeting piece for her and
she's is she the spender out of both of
you I I mean we're probably both equally
spendy yeah you know do you Jonathan if
you were to be honest with us do have
you had
any uh history of maybe a h snide remark
or two with what she has spent on have
you like been sarcastic with it or do
you bring it up in a way that she
doesn't like like I'm just curious that
Dynamic well um when we got together she
was a lot fancier than me so she would
like you know Finer Things and you know
Louis Von and you know stuff like that
so I'm sure I possibly have thrown out a
wow that's a lot of money for something
you right right right okay well I think
one of the biggest you know breakdowns
that I'm hearing is in a perfect world
you know you both would agree on yeah
here's what we're going to spend you
know here's electricity here's our cable
here's like our utilities you know the
basic stuff of life and then us both say
okay you know here's an amount of money
per month that we agree on together that
Jonathan gets that your wife gets and
and together you both say it doesn't
have to be an equal amount of money
right I mean she could say no I I
actually on average spend x amount and
if you guys can afford that and it's not
constraining other parts of the budget
uh to be able to say yeah she can but I
think it's the idea that you guys are
agreeing on where she's spending or I'm
sorry on on how much she is spending
because to me the
amount I think it's the first step and
then the wear would be the second step
but I don't think the wear matters as
much like Winston probably thinks I'm
crazy how much I get my nails done like
do know I mean like he his like the wear
is like a okay um but I think it's the
amount that you guys agree and you're on
the same team to say okay here's what
our overall money looks like and within
this you know you're not her dad that's
going to be ruling over her to tell her
where she can spend her money but we
both agree like this is a reasonable
amount for us to spend on personal
things or even out to eat yeah yeah I
and Jonathan have you kind of seek to
understand when you go hey what's what's
behind this I I feel like you know there
was some some high emotion here when you
shut down there I just want to know like
does this come from somewhere was there
anything in your past or you know why do
you feel like this budget's going to
control us all I'm asking is that we
pre-decide how we spend our paychecks
and we can decide that you have a lot of
money for fun I think she sees like
we're going to have a life of sacrifice
and rice and beans and couponing for the
rest you know rest of your days is that
how she's
feeling I don't know that it's that and
because like I said I when I brought the
bud to her she wouldn't even look at it
so it's not it's not that what kind of
budget did you make was this Exel zero
zero balance or zero dollar budget
whatever it is at the end I'm trying to
do the thing that y'all did did you use
like every dollar of the app or was it
an Excel spreadsheet okay every dollar
good sometimes you know someone shows me
an Excel spreadsheet I shut down okay
she wouldn't look at the numbers at all
nothing and yeah did you ask and you
didn't did did you ask why well our our
communication is sometimes and limited
also so you know when I whenever it's
something that's uncomfortable or you
know not easy just glazed over the top
something more in depth it's kind of
like I don't want to do that she doesn't
go there yeah it feels vulnerable it
feels scary for whatever reason so jonan
I think
that's that's that's the issue right and
we usually say money issues within
marriage are rarely the actual money
issue to your point it's not like she
was like no I need $300 a month not you
know 250 it's it's the it's the
communication something in her does not
feel okay to go there for whatever
reason and George is right it's usually
it comes from somewhere it stems from
somewhere um and for you guys to get on
the same page because if you can
understand and you guys communicate more
effectively in
general uh that's going to help you you
know help help help you effectively
communicate with the money that's going
to help you obviously communicate better
in general but I mean to me that's a
that's where you bring in a third party
sit down and have you guys ever been to
counseling no and I suggest it I'm I'm
usually the you know the the instigator
I'm I'm usually trying and she's because
I've taken care of everything you know
since the
beginning uh I'm I maybe have a little
bit of you know anxiety and and things
to bring up topics to her because every
time I try to bring it up to her it's
just shut
down and so there may be some animosity
and you know all that so that's what we
need to get to the bottom of before we
start talking about money goals we need
to learn what's behind all this how do
we communicate well and I'm going to
send you some tools to help number one
is a copy of my book Breaking Free from
broke I want you guys to read chapter 10
it's called budgeting is freedom I think
it'll show her a different way and I'm
going to send you a copy of Rachel's
book know yourself know your money it's
going to really help her understand why
she thinks the way she thinks around
money and maybe unlock some really cool
things and conversation so we're wishing
you the best Jonathan hang on the line
and Skyler will get you those books this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees every
things backed by their 100% satisfaction
guarantee and shipping is always free
see why blinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to get up to
45% off that's blinds.com rules and
restrictions May
[Music]
apply
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Rachel Cruz if
you want to join us we've got a brand
new event coming up in May on May 10th
and 11th right here in Nashville
Tennessee it's called Total Money
Makeover weekend and whether you've been
listening to us for decades or this is
your first time listening we want you to
to get a little pep in your step when it
comes to your money goals and one
weekend you're going to get a crash
course on everything we teach about
money with brand new content from all of
the Ramsey personalities Rachel Cruz
will be there myself Dave Ramsey Dr John
deloney Jade warshaw Ken Coleman and uh
there's going to be live Q&A throughout
the weekend it's going to be interactive
we have a live smart money happy hour on
Friday night looking forward to that and
this is a really fun weekend we don't do
events boring and so this is the one to
bring that spouse to The Reluctant
friend and if you want to come solo
you're welcome all are welcome here
early bird tickets start at just 99
bucks for a limited time so if you want
the best deal go grab your tickets they
will sell out ramsy solutions.com events
put it in the budget and we'll see you
guys May 10th and 11th right here at the
Ramsey headquarters it's going to be fun
all right open phones at 8825 5225 Kiera
is in Buffalo New York what's going
on hi thank you so much for taking my
call sure
so I am 24 and I have over a half a
million dollars in debt wow is that
Consumer Debt or is that include a
mortgage so that's with my mortgage and
my car loan okay that makes me at least
breathe a little easier so let's walk
through the Consumer Debt how much
Consumer Debt do you have what are the
amounts none
none oh so it's just your
mortgage yeah my mortgage is 49 9,000
what's the
rest um and then my car I owe 54,000
left on it oh okay so that would we
would label anything non-mortgage as
Consumer Debt if that helps oh okay yeah
so you have 54,000 on the car anything
else no and then 490 on the mortgage how
much do you make a
year um I'm self-employed so it kind of
varies some years um my last taxes it
was 250,000 awesome at 24 that's aming
what do you do um I'm a reseller all
right and what's your question
today so my question is I have some
money in the bank I have some in savings
I have a retirement account um but my
biggest question is the car payment kind
of weigh is weighing heavy on me um and
I wanted to get your opinion um on where
like my money should be going kind of so
I have in a high yeld savings account
about
46,000 um so I was wondering I kind of
wanted to get rid of my car like after
listening to you guys um I wish I would
have listen sooner but I I don't think I
need this luxury car um and it was kind
of an Impulse decision just to buy it um
so I was wondering if I should take some
of this money and get rid of my car as
in sell it and downgrade to a different
car with cash well I um I'm engaged so
we have two cars um right now um and we
would just me sharing the one
car is that is that a reasonable
lifestyle switch for you Kira to just go
down to one
car yes okay H how much could you sell
it
for so that's the thing that is um
unfortunate because like I'm um you know
the car um I got different quotes and
stuff so I 0 54 left and my my offer was
37,000 that's like where was this offer
from um well that was CarMax um I've
tried to sell it like personally um like
online um and I'm going into a
dealership on Saturday to do some kind
of like auction thing to see if they can
get maybe even a little bit
more I my guess is private parties going
to be your best bet to sell this for top
dollar versus going to a dealership of
course they're going to lowball you cuz
they're going to it for that higher
amount yeah what kind of car is
it it's a BMW X
okay um what year is it 2019 okay okay
you know I mean yeah I mean if I were
you if you're if you're honest to about
yourself and your day-to-day life and
how that looks that you really don't
feel like you need a car like if that
really is true cuz you make plenty of
money PS you can afford to get another
car maybe a different car car and you
can do something different but don't
feel like a not having a car is your
only option I just want to give you that
window that you have great money saved
if you needed to get a car you could
okay so just and if you wanted to pay
off this car you could yes that's right
and just keep it yeah but if you don't
want it and you're like it's just too
nice I don't need it you are upside down
so what I would try to do almost is just
say hey I want to try to get 40 for it a
little bit more than what was quoted in
a private sell selling situation is
probably the way you're going to do that
and then you're going to have to say
okay I got 14,000 of my own money that
I'm going to have to just you know
finish off the loan and and take that
out of your high yield savings account
yeah we we just call that stupid tax
when we do things that we're like dang
it and just take it out of your high
yield um and then start from there and
if you want a different car or you know
something down the road I would use that
money saved that you have to get a great
used car um yeah that you want so when
when are you guys going to get
married hopefully with like next year
okay so not a date are you guys going to
live in this house that you have a
mortgage on right
now yes you are okay is he coming into
the marriage with any um real
estate um wait what do you mean by that
question like does he does he own a home
too like will he be selling no no this
is our home we bought we bought it
together um last year okay okay he's
also the thing I the only reason why
this car is weighing so heavy on me is
because I know this is like my only debt
but I don't mean to put his business out
there but he has a lot of debt so it's
um and we're just trying we are trying
to like clear his BET right now um so
you're not trying to pay off his debt
though right okay so one thing you have
to realize Kira is yes I understand that
you guys are engaged you're I believe
will get married next year but you guys
legally you're not married you're
roommates I mean from a from a legal
standpoint you realize that right I know
relationally and love and future plans
all the things so with your money the
wisest thing you can do which sounds
harsh I know in your situation because
you guys have already bought a house
together you keep things separate
financially we have talked to so many
people Kira who have used their money to
pay off someone's debts and they start
working together and suddenly the
wedding next year doesn't happen and you
are out all this money and so protecting
yourself in that sense is necessary
during this time and because you have no
legal contract I mean there's there's
nothing legally binding you guys
together if you were married that's a
different story um but from this
standpoint I would not be paying on his
debt so you need to be focused on you he
needs to be focused on him and then you
have to say yeah when we get married we
do become one all of this then we can
work as a team but I would not be doing
that until then until you say I do and
you sign that marriage license and
there's a ring on the finger you guys
are not I would not work together as one
when it comes to the money now you guys
can be encouraging and all of that but I
would be have very separate Financial
lives at this
point okay that makes sense and I should
have mentioned like the car would be his
that we' be using so you'd be paying on
his loan so there's a loan on his car
yeah that you would be splitting the
payment um I actually just asked him he
didn't answer but I think it's around
like 40,000 I wouldn't do any of this I
wouldn't do that just go get your own
car with
cash don't pay on a car that you don't
even own yeah that's not even in your
name you you have
no the point to get rid of this car is
to get rid of the payment and you're
just going to take on another payment
but less with one car right yeah yeah I
wouldn't do that honestly I if I were
you I would get rid of this car because
I think it's a good exercise for you
you're 24 you're like I made a crazy
purchase I shouldn't have I shouldn't
have bought it and I if I were you I
would go get you know a $110,000
whatever whatever go drive that he needs
to work on his stuff I mean like his
debt uh his income all of that needs to
be his this does not need to be your
responsibility because what what
concerns me a little bit and I could be
reading into it is that you're so
responsible you're obviously extremely
bright you're making $250,000 as a 24
year old I mean like you're a go-getter
okay and I'm not saying he isn't but in
some cases what we find is that he gets
the benefit and rapes the benefit of all
the greatness that you have but then you
get no benefit from from a legal
standpoint CU you're not married so I I
would be very cautious in all of that
sharing and and buying a house together
too the this is for the listener out
there do not put both of your names on a
deed of a house if you are not legally
married it gets you in a mess you guys
it'll get you in a
[Music]
[Applause]
mess
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumps
some payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
[Applause]
Ramsey
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campell joined by Rachel Cruz the number
to call is
a825
5225 the Ramsey Show question of the day
is brought to you by neighborly your hub
for home services from repairs and
maintenance to Home Improvement projects
winter can bring some challenges for
homeowners and you need neighborly
helpful winter checklist and it's free
you can download it for free at
neighborly
in South Carolina my husband and I are
on baby step 2 we have an SUV that is
paid off and my husband wants to finance
a second vehicle it's kind of the
opposite of baby step to there but uh he
has $112,000 to put towards the purchase
I thought he was looking in the range of
35 to 45,000 but he now wants one that
costs
$90,000 he only wants to use the truck
for eight months and then take advantage
of the buyback program from the
dealership and get a cheaper vehicle
then we can't afford an $800 car payment
for the next eight months and I don't
trust the buy bre buyback program how do
I make him see that the numbers just
don't work to finance a vehicle right
now I have asked him to find a vehicle
that we can afford with the $112,000 or
he can use RSV and I will drive an older
vehicle this argument has been going on
for 6 months and I don't know how much
more our marriage can take the stress
has gotten the worse and I'm currently
between jobs and my income is very low
right now goodness sounds like a lot
Jenny um it sounds like he is coping
with a marriage on the Rocks she's
unemployed they're between incomes and
he's like I'm going to go get a giant
truck to make me feel better about all
this just want some kind of comfort in
my life right now because everything
else seems to be chaotic yeah this man
is reverting to a child he's like
Benjamin buttoning Rachel real time
finances right in front of our eyes um
she's right I mean if you need some
confirmation yes oh yeah you have
$12,000 to purchase a car but Jenny I
think you're asking the wrong question
she says how do I make them see that the
numbers just don't work numb numbers
it's the fact that you guys are
obviously not on the same page you're
trying to do a program and get out of
debt while he's adding on debt like
you're literally counteracting each
other it doesn't make sense and so what
ends up happening is exactly what is
happening sadly is it causes a lot of
stress it causes a lot of fights because
you're both not walking the same path
you're you're running into each other
and so that's going to cause tension and
so for you guys I would just pan way
back and say okay as our family what do
we want money to look like what what
does this look like for us and if you
guys can't get on the same page with
that value system then yeah I mean I I
think we said it in an earlier call but
it's true I'm like that means there's
you're probably not on the same page on
a lot of things in life and so working
and finding that unity and even if
that's bringing in you know a marriage
counselor or a therapist to get you guys
back on that same page and and and
always know with marriage you guys that
there's always going to be opposites
okay so there's always going to be one
person that always kind of wants the
bougier thing probably the one that's
like ah we're fine here or one more of a
spender one's more of a Savor like
you're always going to have these
different money Personalities in a
marriage so we're not saying you have to
be uniformed and just identical robots
together um but the overall big picture
is that you want to be walking the same
path and that usually comes down to
value system a value system conversation
that obviously you guys are on separate
pages so I think that looking at that as
the issue uh is where I would start yeah
this is so tough cuz this marriage is
only it's only going to go grow further
apart if he makes this decision
and it's going to be a harder decision
to undo and it's going to cause so much
resentment on Jenny's side of like she
is not going to feel like she has a vote
in this marriage if he goes and does
this behind her back in front of her
back no matter how he does it it's going
to screw things up even more so she
needs to have to come to Jesus meeting
with him and go listen I don't feel safe
I'm trying to do this plan this marriage
is not going well we need to get on the
same page you need to act like an adult
and have some delayed gratification and
that means one day you can have that
truck when we can pay for it in cash
when we're not in debt but right now is
not the time to go make more terrible
decisions yeah cuz again take the money
piece out of this you guys like it's
just the fact of it's just disrespect
right like if one spouse is pleading
with another on something you would
listen to that what would you do if
Winston went out and financed a $90,000
truck while you guys were in debt
actively trying to get out well that's
the thing is I'm like yeah we can talk
about the money piece about how that
pulls you backwards and all of that but
it's a complete respect thing I'm like
there's a level that you're you're
obviously not being heard in your money
probably not in other parts of your
marriage and Jenny like I don't you know
I mean you s it sounds like a such a
desperate situation um which is so sad
and it's so difficult and there's a lot
of couples that are walking this road
right now but it's so much more than
just the money decision it's the fact
that he's not hearing her respecting her
and and at least like I like it's one
thing if he's like no JY I think you're
wrong but you know what I'll come down
at least go to $35,000 compromise it's
just a complete like middle finger is
what it feels like like I'm going to go
do whatever the I want and that's not a
marriage that's not a healthy marriage
I'm not here rag on the truck Bros
Rachel cuz I get a lot of flack for that
but there's something about opinion on
trucks there's something I'm not going
to even call them men in trucks I'm
going to send Boys in trucks cuz men in
trucks I have no problem with Winston
Cruz has an awesome truck I got to ride
in it that thing is awesome that's right
boys in trucks and by boys I mean grown
men who are financing $90,000 trucks to
cope that's not okay and I will uh fight
against that every single day fight the
good fight George that's what I'm doing
in Winston the Lord's the Lord's calling
on your life Rachel I had to crawl into
Winston's Tundra it was so high up I was
like is there a ladder you can throw
down for me stop it's not a raised truck
it's a regular truck George truck all
right Jillian is up next in Salt Lake
City Jillian welcome to the ramsy show
hi what's going
on so we are we've gotten ourselves into
a situation and we're wondering the best
way to get out of it um so we are
looking to see does it makes sense to
pull 401k to pay off a HELOC how old are
you I just turned 40 on
Saturday happy birthday happy big
birthday that's a big milstone and also
please never do this okay I know happy
birthday don't do it so you're I
understand you're You' got this big
helck and you're looking for some kind
of shortcut to go how do we get out of
this helck but what you're doing doing
is robbing your future self with
penalties and fees on top of that I
would just oh I would just treat it as a
baby step six situation Jillian I would
I would because how much do you owe on
your house mortgage wise so mortgage
wise we're like 450 which it's only 2
and a half% but the HELOC is like 8 and
a half% the payment is killing us yeah
yeah how much do you guys make a
year um which sounds like a lot like uh
it is a lot around 350,000 okay yep it
is a lot but when you're drowning in
payments all over the place it doesn't
feel like a lot yeah we're we're cutting
back as much as we can and obviously we
need to make changes but what was the
HELOC for uh a house Remodel and a pool
as one does it's the American way okay
any other debt um we have a credit card
I have a business that I just started so
I have like $188,000 on a credit card
okay but other than that we have our
cars are paid off um we were debt free
until this pool makes large large
commission checks and we made we about
$170,000 more than we're making now and
we knew that we would get these
commissions and be able to pay this off
and the market turned in his in his you
know where he works and um bonuses are
not coming and so we and then the hel
this is like that's I was gonna say real
life you guys lived out the Christmas
Vacation did you learn nothing from that
movie right you thought this is a
fictional movie it does
and Julian this is a really good lesson
for people this is not to continue to
pick on your situation by any means but
this happens all the time and I can do
this mentally and emotionally you spend
the money before you get the money right
you're like oh oh my gosh we're going to
make what oh this is going so well we're
this year we're for sure going to make
and you already spend it right whether
in your emotions concept Deb is spending
money you don't have and then hoping you
have it later yeah but it but it's
different when you feel like no I'm
supposed to have a $170,000 Bon you know
and then yeah you don't have it so so
yeah I think it's just a I think it's a
pain Point Julian for you guys so I
would just I would I would pay off I
would pay off your is it the car the
18,000 credit card credit card credit
card that that's try I'm sorry for the
business yep I would I would focus you
guys to pay that off get that out okay
because that's going to just free up
some mental space because I would then
move forward do you guys have savings at
all um no okay so I would save up 3 to
six months of expenses after you pay off
this card and then um and then I would
be funding
retirements um you know look at the kids
college stuff but I would I would attack
this HELOC first uh and then your
mortgage but I would I would go ahead
and start the baby steps uh but I would
use this helck as kind of a baby step 6A
and then your mortgage is 6B but I would
I would put it there and making 350
Jillian you guys are going to get out of
this faster than you think but it's
going to take some deep sacrifice y'all
been leaving Lita Loca and now you're
broka so you're going to get out of it
we have hope in you and Faith so call us
back when you're debt free we'll
celebrate with you and happy belated
birthday this is the ramsy
[Music]
show hey guys Ramsey solution started
small and grew fast because of that
rapid growth there were times when our
systems slowed us down that's why we
switch to net Suite it works for us and
it'll help your business too whether
you're starting on a card table like I
did or you're well on your way to
becoming a multi-million doll company
netsuite can scale with you and help you
communicate and plan better because you
know your day-to-day up and down and
sideways but accounting analytics and
supply chain are on another level so
maybe you're just not techsavvy that can
be okay next Suite will help at your
speed and what whatever your situation
more than
37,000 companies use netsuite to know
their numbers and their business better
so check out netw Suite today and find
out how they can help you become the
business you want to be 5 or 30 years
from now and right now you can download
netsuite's free kpi checklist designed
to give you consistently excellent
performance at nets.com Ramsey that's
netsuite.com
Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm George Campell joined by Rachel Cruz
this is the ramsy show and if you enjoy
this show you should check out smart
money happy hour co-hosted by myself and
Rachel Cruz we have a blast and if you
need to like send someone the show
that's not too heavy too intense smart
money happy hour is it's a breath of
fresh air there's lots of laughs and you
kind of we sneakily teach you money
things while you don't even know it you
don't even know it's like a what our
writer Savannah said she was at the nail
salon and some gen Z girls were like hey
you know that Dave guy she's like yeah
she's like well his daughter has a
really cool podcast I love it we're
talking about smart body Happ the nail
salon talk about current
events pop culture and money Rachel's
like the cool sister it's the best and
I'm the cool Uncle I guess Uncle George
that's right all right Gabriella is up
next in Mallen Texas Gabriella what's
going
on hi guys thank you for taking my call
so my question is my ex-boyfriend left
me with an RV payment and I do not want
to pay it oh my gosh so what happened
you guys so he took it to go work and
could no longer a wor the payment on it
and left it to me last weekend and was
like here you go here's the RV with the
payment what do you mean left it to you
whose name is on the loan it is under my
name we were together for 10 years um I
got it for for him to he had to go work
in the oil field and um he we split up
about a year ago and he he can't afford
it anymore he so he brought it back to
me and I'm left with it oh no
shoot well Gabrielle you'll never do
that again will you I've learned my
lesson oh no you know we talked to
somebody earlier in the hour and her and
her boyfriend well fiance they don't
really have a date I don't think a
wedding date we asked but yeah both
their houses their names are on the deed
of the house and I just thought oh no no
no no um you're a great uh I guess
poster child of what can happen when you
sign on to Deb and buy things with
people you're not married to and I'm so
sorry I mean on top of the hurt from
this long-term relationship being over
and it was a year ago though so now
you're like well crap I gota what is
what's left on the RV loan and what is
it
worth it is the balance left is around
48,000 and looking it up it's worth
around
30,000 so you're $188,000
underwater basically for some reason
they took
like the prices in RVs were just
expensive when I bought it and have
dropped well that's been the theme on
the show for the last week or month is
everyone is underwater on vehicles and
things with wheels because it was really
expensive and they had good intentions
and then the market turned and now
everyone's underwater so there's only
two ways to go about this number one is
you need to come up with $18,000 in cash
in order to sell it and pay off the loan
or number two you go get a personal loan
for the different of that 18,000 to get
out from under this do you have any
money uh yeah I have around 10,000 in
savings good and any other
debt yeah well yes I have a mortgage um
I pay my vehicle but my vehicle is
actually a leas and um I hadn't learned
my lesson at the time but I have a
bedroom set under under my name that
somebody else owes about $3,000 of that
really no credit card debt um somebody
else
owes yes it's under my name so
technically I owe it but and are they
paying are they paying on it or you're
yes and no okay oh gosh is this is this
family is it a friend that you like said
hey I'll is it's it's family it's a
family member oh gosh I think you need
to stop being generous with money you
don't have Gabriella that's what's been
happening it's a theme in your life you
sound like such a sweet wonderful person
know how much she make a
year uh so this year I made I'm actually
a nurse and with covid um I made really
good money uh 2022 kind of gone down
some so this year I made
133 but it will probably drop again this
year because uh there's no more covid
crisis so that's just how it works not
if I can help it you're going to be out
there busting your tail over time doing
Uber Eats and door Dash and instacart
whatever it takes you you're climbing
out of this thing and uh I think you're
you're not scared of work which is great
and uh we got to start with the smallest
debt here which it sounds like is this
bedroom
set yeah yeah I think you just pay it
off and if they ever pay you any more
for it great you can apply that don't
expect it don't wait around it yeah be
be done with it okay even if it's um
zero interest I should pay that one off
especially if it's zero interest all of
it okay we're done with payments we're
done with debt you make too much you're
too successful and you're too smart to
ever do this stuff again
regardless of the interest
rate does that track Gabriella are you
with us on this yes we we are team
Gabriella and so we want you to win and
that's going to mean you have you know
if you count up all your debt and if you
want to get out of the lease you can
look at the early buyout amount and uh
see if that's going to be worth it for
you to do now uh otherwise you turn the
car in and then you need to go get
another car but don't just get another
lease okay it's the most expensive way
to get a vehicle and dealerships love it
cuz they make the most money off of
these
leases okay so no more leasing no more
leasing buy your next car with cash
which is gonna be tough when is the
lease
up um in about two more years okay yeah
I would look at the early buyout I would
just kind of do some research in that
but then in the meantime between now and
two years be saving some cash um knowing
that you're going to have to replace
this car but I would take yeah this 10
grand Gabriella I would pay off the um
yep the bedroom
set uh and then the be looking at the 18
that you'll probably have to take a loan
out for uh for the remainder of that RV
after you sell it okay so I shouldn't
give it back to the bank and then let
them sell it and then me pay the
difference you're saying to have the RV
repossessed yes I wouldn't do that no I
wouldn't do that because I would go on
your credit I would yeah I would I would
just find the private sale um list it
sell it yourself get as much as you can
for it obviously and then yeah you'll
have to have have a loan for the
difference and then you'll be working
your way out of
that oh okay yeah I wish we had better
news the good news is you make great
money you make six figures we've seen
bigger scarier numbers than this but
it's the hurt and shame and guilt and
baggage and oh my gosh I'm so stupid you
got to just pick yourself up and go
listen that doesn't Define me I'm going
to make different decisions Gabrielle is
it just you are you single kids yes it
it's just me and my two girls okay so
you do have two girls okay how old are
they I have a nine-year-old and a
three-year-old okay so sweet that's so
great okay so what you're probably going
to be doing I mean where you can work
extra and even if it's you know at night
online or something like if there's like
something that you can do to find that
extra money but with this 133 I mean I
would act like I would I would tighten
everything up and I mean give yourself a
goal to say I'm going to act like I make
70,000 a year or whatever it is and then
find that difference to to have an end
point to say okay I could be completely
debt free be done with all of this and
start fresh not owing anyone anything
and and start this whole process I'm
like that that you could do this in 18
months Gabrielle I mean if you really
focused and did this um the Carly Le you
know kind of hangs in the balance of
what you decide there but being able to
have no payments and this income going
to you and your girls and you guys
keeping all of it that's the goal we
want for you have you been through
Financial Peace
University no okay so if you hold on the
line scholar is going to pick up and
we're going to gift that to you as as
well as every dollar premium which is
our budgeting app and so what I want you
to do Gabrielle is wa is watch these
lessons even binge them uh there's going
to be seven lessons and I want you to go
through and and watch all of this and
really get a game plan to say okay here
is how I take control of my money and
what that's going to teach you is
everything from budgeting to getting out
of debt to saving up for an emergency
fund uh to investing to your kids
college I mean it kind of runs the gamut
of everything and it's all packaged in
there and so to be able to walk through
that and apply this stuff Gabrielle
because what you've already witnessed
and experienced is that money it's
personal finance it's 80% Behavior it's
only 20% head knowledge you're going to
watch these videos and be like I knew
that I knew I shouldn't probably
co-signed some furniture for a family
member I know that I probably okay now
okay you know you're going to get all
that but actually changing the behavior
and doing it is going to be the key to
you winning and I believe in you I know
you can do this Gabriella we're we're
cheering you on so hold on the line
Skylar will pick up that's the theme of
this hour don't spend money you don't
have especially with people you're not
married to that puts this hour of the
Ramsay show in the books my thanks to my
co-host Rachel Cruz all the folks in the
booth and you America thank you so much
for listening we'll be back before you
know
[Music]
it
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George camel joined by
bestselling author and all-around great
person Rachel Cruz and we are here for
you America answering your question
questions about money and life and all
the predicaments and challenges and
maybe some wins that you're facing 8825
5225 is the number to call to join the
conversation Olivia kicks us off in
Buffalo New York Olivia welcome to the
ramsy
show hi thank you so much for taking my
call I'm a huge fan of the Ramsey Show
especially Dave he's awesome we
agree yeah love him um so my question
for you all today is my sister took
advantage of Our Sick mom skipped town
and stole my inheritance what should I
do oh my gosh Olivia what do you mean
took advantage of your sick mom took
advantage well um okay she uh took over
the family business even though it
wasn't left to her uh she convinced my
mom to become the power of attorney and
healthc Care proxy and transferred all
money to her own account oh
wow wow what what kind she also sold my
mom's house and moved my mom into the
family
business into the business into the like
the office
yes okay what what kind of sickness is
your mom have she had cancer she died 3
months ago oh my gosh so sorry Olivia do
you have any other
siblings no I'm the eldest I'm 40 years
old my sister is approximately 37 years
old she lived with both of my parents
who passed from cancer and um she has
skipped town and has not buried my
mom where is your
mom uh she she sorry my sister has her
ashes okay she's created oh my gosh did
you and your sister have a relationship
before all of this we did it was I
thought it was a lovely relationship um
and then things started getting weird
when my father passed away 5 years ago
and then my mom got cancer and I believe
she felt entitled as the power of
attorney to all money all estate all
inheritance and she's gone she changed
her number she left town so from from a
legal standpoint did your mom have and
your dad you know any documentation
legally like in a will of what your
inheritance is and then she went and
changed it as power of attorney or is
there a will out there that you are you
are owed essentially your
inheritance there is a will that my mom
wrote I have never seen it my sister
attempted to change the will one month
prior to death but they never got it
signed so there is a handwritten will
and not sure if it was done with a
lawyer but um I've never seen the will
okay and you have no point of contacts
for anyone that might have information
on this I've tried to reach out to the
lawyers and they said Katherine or I'm
sorry
Olivia um it was never signed therefore
it's not valid the will yeah I mean and
they've no version that is
signed correct oh man
Olivia what's the question the question
would be do I keep my own peace and
Sanity and money and move forward with
my life or do I try to
um fight it essentially yeah I mean the
only the only issue with all of that
because I don't mind the fighting
Injustice I mean there's a there you
know we're not scared of that but I
don't know if you have any legal
documents that will uphold in court to
to fight your side like I don't know if
there's any legal documentation to show
your side cuz from a legal perspective
you know you could be lying as much as
she is right I'm not saying you are
Olivia but like there's no um there's no
proof otherwise we need some kind of
paper trail there needs to be like some
some level of documentation to in order
to when you hire lawyers for them to
fight this in the court system and I
just don't know if you if you have that
have you contacted a lawyer yes I have
what did they say was a lawyer he said
that it may not be worth it because
number one uh there may not be any money
left over that's true yeah and right so
it may
cost five to $10,000 for a lawyer and I
may not get anything after all yeah how
much was the estate worth like how much
did your parents have do you do you have
any idea well uh the house was sold for
344,000 uh there were many leans against
the house okay and I was uh my sister
has all of that money okay so there were
some Lanes was that all of your
inheritance or was there other money
that was supposed to be given to
you um that was probably all of my
inheritance okay so wasn't retirement
accounts other assets cash things like
that no there was the family business
but that's another topic um I believe
just the money from the house would be
part of my inheritance yeah I mean that
would be 120 for you if you just 5050
and then but we don't know all these
leans against say the leans against it
to be would be diminished too so I'm
like I don't know that there would be
much here for you based on how
complicated this whole thing is and was
I agree Olivia well what's so hard is
I'm like you've lost your mom there
hasn't there's a feeling of no closure
your parents lost your sister in this
there's no closure there's I mean the
the whole the whole way it went down for
you Olivia is just it's just terrible
and I wish I had better guidance or
direction for you to to get some justice
in this but I do you have any money
right
now yes how much oh myself yeah oh yes I
work I I make a 70,000 a year I'm a
surgical nurse um I I'm married I have a
dog um we're doing we're doing just fine
I I just yeah uh this situation is a
strange one um it's very sad and and
you're in fact right I lost mom dad and
a sister yep
yep but um and even the closure with
your mom and her Ash you know what I
mean like like that would probably be
the the step I would take of trying to
get contact with your sister but you
have no way to even know where she is
how to get in touch with her she is off
the planet at this point
correct goodness uh she had three cell
phones she changed the last number and
has not responded via email we did have
a lovely funeral for my mom in church
she attended that funeral but since then
she has taken off with the ashes and all
of the money I don't even understand
that part that just feels so strange
well I mean Olivia honestly if I were in
your position and as much as you can
find the closure in it I would I would I
so sad to say you close a chapter in a
book from your family but she's C I mean
she sounds crazy the way you've
presented it to us like she sounds crazy
dangerous if you did her that's right
I'm like she stole like like it's
immoral the things she has done and so
if I were you I'd create I mean not that
you have to even draw boundaries cuz
there's no relationship there but I mean
I would in my heart just there's a level
you got to just say all right that I'm
done I can't I'm not going to keep
fighting in in this wheel because even
that with the inheritance and all of
that it just muddles the piece of what's
happened with your parents you know at
that point and so for you Olivia I think
it's in the healthiest retrospect for
you to to move onor I'm going to send
you copy of Dr John delon's book own
your past change your future to help you
grieve all
[Music]
this hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to Churchill
mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsy show I'm
George camell joined by Rachel Cruz if
you want to call us and talk about your
life and your money you can do so at
5225 Lisa is up next in Indianapolis
Lisa welcome to the show hi guys thanks
for taking our call sure how um I'm a
I'm a newer listener to your show and my
husband and I are wondering if it would
be beneficial to pay off our mortgage
early oo well the question is why
wouldn't you want to pay it off early
because we don't have too many years
left to pay on it um we can pay it off
if we want to I just like I said I'm a
newer listener so I'm just intrigued
about the de free process and wanting to
know if it's a good decision or not yeah
how old are you guys uh we're 57 okay
and how much do you have left on the
mortgage uh 85,000 okay and how much is
the house
worth um anywhere between 7 to 800
depending on what site you look at yeah
good for you guys and you have money
saved we do non-retirement
correct he had a buy out from a job
sance okay how much is in how much do
you guys have
saved 143
okay that's
awesome um and how much do you guys make
a
year uh he makes 230 okay that's great
any other debt credit cards car loans no
the only thing we have uh we have a
long-term care insurance plan that we
have payments on for three more years
okay okay good for you guys wow um I
mean yeah Lisa I think there is
something to be said about having
absolutely no payments and when you free
up a mortgage payment per month you know
what you guys can do whether it is spend
it invest it put it for retirement give
it there is such there's such Freedom
financially when you don't owe anyone
anything and then the flip side of it
too Lisa that not many people talk about
it's the freedom just emotionally I'm
like when you have no payments and a
pandemic hits and everyone is panicked
about their jobs you don't you don't
have have any bills like there's there's
no one that you owe at that point you
know so it's amazing how much um risk
that debt is associated with that we get
used to As Americans that we just carry
around and just assume it's
normal right and when it's finally done
and that house is completely yours
there's no payments there's no Bank
associated with your life like there is
there's something so powerful in that
and that's on just the emotional side
obviously not even just the financial
side because I guess you guys have a
good interest rate I'm
assuming correct yeah yeah because some
people make the argument we just keep
the money invested you'll make more on a
rate of return and with it invested
versus you know paying it off because
it's at two and a half percent or you
know yeah people go down the math the
math route which we understand like we
we can do math like we get it but again
it's it's this other piece Lisa that um
that people just don't put into the
formula and that other piece is a level
of risk that debt will always assoc have
associated with with it yeah the reality
of having no payment is so much better
than the potential Assumption of the
spread you could get if you left the
money invested and uh we Rachel and I
both don't have mortgage payments and I
have zero regrets I never look back and
go well if I just invested them I could
have we're going to be fine and so are
you guys cuz the because the other side
of that coin too Le says you know if you
had a paid off house would you go borrow
on your
house no okay so then that answers your
question some people say yes and they go
build pools and remodel their home so
I'm proud you guys what's in your nest
egg how much do you have in
retirement um a lot I mean like 1.85
right now in retirement and but then
we've got a couple of Ross and other
Investments as well on that's so great
so you're worth millions of dollars
here's the deal too Lisa if we if we're
all just being honest here you wouldn't
have to you could keep paying the
mortgage payment and you're you're going
to be fine right like you are but what
we try to do on the show is to get you
the most the fastest right way to this
idea of building wealth and leaving a
legacy and all of it and part of that
plan is paying off the mortgage so you
have the money okay I would do it I
would do it and if you regret it Lisa
you can you can you can borrow on the
house bank's happy to give you more
Monopoly money but listen you pay it off
you still have 58,000 left over just
from what you told us yeah and making
great money and all what's your mortgage
payment um we pay $24 00 a month and
that includes property taxes and
insurance uh I believe so no because we
pay our own taxes our own property tax I
want to do some fun math with you that's
uh 2400 a month you said correct time 12
months in a year that's almost 29 Grand
that you could then invest let's say
right in the next 10 years that money
could turn into
$462,000 if you just take your mortgage
payment and invest it for 10 years
okay you could have an extra half
million and you could also give more you
could spend more you could retire
earlier and so it just gives you more
flexibility more freedom more options
and margin and so that's why we
recommend it and you guys have done so
well without us well done Lisa so that's
just one two people's opinion yep all
right well wonderful that's kind of kind
of what I was leaning towards but my
husband's like well let's let's ask them
so I said okay I love it your husband's
a great man tell to call in hope you
guys do it all right Angie's up next in
Chicago Angie welcome to the show thank
you how can we
help so we have an opportunity to move
overseas for about three to five years
um three years for sure and we would
take about a 65% pay cut to do this and
I'm wondering what your thoughts are
whether or not you think the experience
would be worth
it uh what's the what's the situation is
it a work thing what what what's going
on yeah it it is a work thing for my
husband he would take a 30% pay cut and
I would not be able to work okay um so
we would go from making about 300,000 a
year to just over a hundred and we have
four kids we have one in college whose
college is paid for already then we have
a 15-year-old 12-year old and a
5-year-old oh wow would they come too I
they would come yeah George three years
you never know you know what if these
kids are prodig like I'm out of here
years that's big well what does the
whole family want to do are they all
excited about this what yeah what what's
the family
feeling um the the middle two well the
oldest one would not come because he's
in college and he has one year left and
he'll go do his thing um he may come you
know for visits and travel but the
middle two are not super excited about
it but I think that once they get there
they will love it they love is it so
it's in Eastern Europe and Poland okay
okay um well yeah I don't think George
and I are going to be able to answer the
question is it worth it um the paycuts I
think that's a
complete I mean some you look at a
budget and look at Cost of Living and
can you financially afford to go down to
100,000 in Poland for those many years
uh that's a different situation but I'm
more concerned about the relational
aspect the emotional aspect you know do
you want to do it
Angie I do you do does your does your
husband he does okay think it would be
really good for the kids um we do we do
move a lot so they are used to moving um
I think it would be good for them to
just just see you know how people live
differently and we'd have the
opportunity to travel all over Europe
sure for them to to see different
cultures and whatnot um and I'm not I
don't think I'm too worried about
financially us affording it because we
don't have any bills other than a
mortgage and we I think it would be
wiser if we just sold our home so we
didn't have to worry about paying that
and the company pays our housing while
we're over there that's great what kind
of job does he does he have uh he works
in Compu on computers okay that's
awesome yeah I mean I think it's one of
those things um I'm just trying to think
you know with my kids I have younger
ones than you though they're eight six
and four but I I mean I think at the end
of the day you guys are the parents
Angie and if you both you your husband
are like hey this is a lifestyle choice
we want to make as our family like you
you ultimately get that say right
12-year-old doesn't get to tell the
family what to do but I would but as
George said like I mean I would um very
much as much as you can get there Buy in
but it will be sad I think that's a I
mean if I was a freshman in high school
leaving all my friends for the rest of
High I mean there there will be a a
that's a big shift right for them so I
would want to give the proper weight and
understanding of that but I think at the
end of the day Angie if you and your
husband both want to do this I mean yes
one of my best friends literally you're
living her dream right now this is all
she wants to she does she's like I just
want to get out of here and do something
different and I guess if you hate it you
can come back to the States and it
sounds like he can make some good money
going back to what he was doing yeah
absolutely hope that answers your
question Angie thanks for the call this
is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campell joined by Rachel Cruz
this is your show give us a call at
aa825
5225 well Rachel we took a call about
paying off the mortgage early and it's a
fun conversation to see what that money
can turn into oh yeah invested versus
just sending a regular old mortgage
mortgage payment to the bank yeah and
there's so many mortgage types out there
and most of them are truly just crap and
they're meant to give more money to the
banks and lenders and less money in your
pocket and so I want to take a look at
an example of the 15-year mortgage which
is the one we recommend versus the
30-year mortgage to show people exactly
what the numbers look like and not we're
not going to get super nerdy I'm not
going to talk amortization schedules
rightel but I did want to look at this
graph from our blog article on the 15
verse 30 so we're going to look at a
$300,000 house which I understand you're
all like where can you find those this
is back in the day kids let's say you
did 20% % down on this $300,000 house
that's
$60,000 tracking mhm that means you'd
get a mortgage for
$240,000 so let's look at that same
mortgage on a 15-year and a 30-year in
the blue if you're watching on YouTube
is the mortgage loan the Orange is the
amount of interest you pay so here's the
shocking part on a 15-year uh fixed rate
loan with an interest rate of 3 and a
half% the monthly payment is 1,700 bucks
and the total interest you'd pay is
$69,000 if you just paid every single
payment perfectly for 15 years right
right on the 30 year you're going to
have a higher interest rate at 4% now
the payment is lower which is why most
people do it it's 1146 instead of 76
1716 but the total interest you pay on
that 30-year over 30 years of payments
is
$172,000 that you just gave away to the
lender yep that is shocking almost
$100,000 more and that's again I get the
interest rate people are probably like
it's at 6% the numbers
wor with a 30 at% right right so the
math is just magnified you're paying
$350,000 on that 8% loan so that's why
we want your mortgage paid off ASAP
because this interest you guys I mean it
does it just it it racks up and you see
it so you're paying over $100,000 more
in interest to have the 30 or over the
15 I know people have great intentions
they say well George I'll pay it off
like a 15 yeah and I'm like the people
that really want to build wealth and
they don't want to wait till they're 65
what they're doing is they pay off their
15-year Mortgage in s or 10 years right
right that's the average we found with
people who follow the baby steps our our
millionaire study 10 years is what it
takes for them to pay it off yes baby
steppers seven years on average to pay
off their mortgage and so that's very
encouraging to see how much money you
can save and I actually shared this in
my book Rachel I wanted to see the
numbers for myself and my wife when we
paid off our home so you ready for this
we paid off our mortgage back in 2021
and I did the math on it we would have
shelled out if we we paid ours off
aggressively in like 26 months cuz we're
weird but it was on a 15-year fixed rate
if we just made payments for 15 years we
would have paid almost 50 Grand in
interest had we opted for the 30-year
loan we would have paid over $100,000 in
interest so instead because we paid it
off even earlier we paid just nine grand
in interest by being crazy my go and you
chose well in your home and that's our
big point you guys I mean some people
are like oh my gosh mod affordable home
yes and and and we know the housing
we're not completely oblivious to what
is going on in the world like we we
understand rates are up housing prices
are up and depending on your area yes a
starter home could be $800,000 in some
areas right so like this is this is a
reality but the hard thing is George is
a money doesn't have emotion money
doesn't or math doesn't math doesn't
care it is what it is and so you can't
justify okay I'm going to go and buy a
house that's my payment is half of my
income just so I can say I have a house
because you're going to feel screwed
every month it's going to feel like oh
my gosh we have no money because you
have too much house and so expectations
on when you buy a home what kind of home
you buy have shifted in the last three
years and people even some drastic
things they're they're moving States
even because they're like we just can't
afford longterm what we want our life to
look like because of this because again
you guys it's it's the math and that's
what we have to always go back to
regardless of how much it sucks that's
the reality and so we want want you to
build wealth get there the fastest right
way and what we found is when you do a
15-year it forces you into a formula
that makes you pay it off faster even
though you're probably going to pay it
off even faster if you're doing the baby
steps which is great but um you know
it's a it's a hard conversation George
and what's even Difficult about and i'
be curious just your prediction on this
with just the housing market because in
my head when rates go down you guys the
demand is suddenly going to open up
everyone's going to freaking rush to buy
a house because have gone down and then
that's going to drive the prices up
again so if you are in a position where
you can put you know 5% down 10% down
20% down and it's again we we use the
15year here at Ramsey because we want
you in a formula that's getting you out
of De we don't like any kind of debt we
just won't yell at you if you do a
15year fixed rate mortgage yeah and it's
you know 25% of your take-home pay
that's kind that's the formula we use
and you're ready to do it do it because
we people thought the bottom of the
market was going to crash what last year
that's what everyone kept saying and
it's like it's going to crash and it was
we were we kept saying it's not it's
supply and demand when it comes to this
stuff you guys and so if you are in a
position to buy having a home is a great
investment we want you to do it the
right way though absolutely and I
understand for those that want to buy a
home it's it's painful right now let's
call it yeah it does it's harder than it
was for your parents yes and the harder
thing is it's not going to get it's not
going to get easier so make a plan get
out of debt get the emergency fund start
saving up that down payment adjust your
expectations this doesn't have to be
your dream home just get get in the game
and that might be a condo or a town home
and it might be in an area further out
from the city and it might not have all
of the acutron and the fancy kitchen
island that you dreamed of but at least
you're a homeowner and that's a great
thing be proud of that always
interesting me George especially houses
cars these like big parts of our
lifestyle when you look back you know in
the 70s and 80s on average a square foot
of a house was 1400 now it's up to like
2600 on average right the average single
family home and so our expectations on
life in general in general have changed
if we don't have the quartz countertop
we're throwing a tissy fit what we've
just yeah categorized as this normal way
of living when you look back I I look
back on childhood pictures of like my
our home growing up and I'm like it's
brown carpet I mean it's just not
aesthetically pleasing but it's okay and
now it's like you can't even imagine
having x y and z you know what I mean
like because social media reality TV I
me all this stuff we've been painted and
this picture of what life should look
like has been in front of us for so long
for so long that it's normal and God
forbid you know kids share the bathroom
like I mean like you know all of that so
so again it's it doesn't make it easier
but I think we do have to have some
level of grounding to say gosh what we
expect in life like it or not the
lifestyle creep thing it it is real from
a generational standpoint too and you
used to have to wheel down uh Windows
George in our cars that was my first car
you would wheel down a window and
everyone was okay with that but like oh
my gosh could you imagine you know
what's really embarrassing though I'll
say this is the worst part about having
manual windows whenever someone I knew
pulled up next to me and I couldn't
reach over far enough to get to the
passenger side window to talk to them
yes so I would just like wave at them
awkwardly I know cuz I wasn't trying to
pull a you know pull a hamstring think
about our cell phones noia cricket oh
that was that was the that was it times
it was no internet you didn't have email
but so used to having all the all the
information everything we want right
there in our hands right so I'm like
it's to the little things of our
expectations and I'm part of it too I'm
guilty of this so you're part of the
problem I may be part of the problem not
pointing fingers but no that's good
that's a good kind of level us us outs
yes but also don't make a terrible
decision out of fear or like this fomo
or I'll never get a house so I just need
to jump in now cuz you'll be the next
caller calling the Ramsey Show saying
Rachel I think I need to sell the house
because we're so broke and so stressed
and we go the home should be a blessing
not a burden and what happens when you
do it before you're ready is it becomes
a burden so uh Rachel you talked about
forecasting the 20 24 housing market
that's literally the YouTube video I
uploaded to my Channel today stop it
George we are like twins you know twins
they have the twin thing they say that
you could like feel like that's us
energy happening on the show today
brother sister energy we I like so if
you want that believe it in 8 minutes
you can go to my YouTube channel and
watch the forecast of the 2024 housing
market I even from another mother I did
the weatherman thing we got a green
screen I got to be weatherman on the
channel how happy were you it talking
about like northeasterly winds and
cumulous clouds it brought me so much
joy it's always been a dream of mine
Rachel if this whole whole thing falls
apart I'm going to go be a meteorologist
traff I'll be traffic guys can be
weather this is not and then Ken can be
uh politics commentary okay maybe not
yeah this was this has been fun thanks
for being the dream killer Rachel this
is the ramsy
[Music]
show
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Rachel Cruz this
hour if you're enjoying the show do me a
quick favor the show is free what I'm
going to ask you to do is free it'll
just take you a second hit the Subscribe
button wherever you're listening or
watching or hit the follow button leave
us a review and make it kind we like
those the best and then share it with a
friend that's one of the best ways we
can spread our message of Hope is by you
telling another friend hey add this to
your podcast repertoire watch this video
on YouTube I enjoyed it I think you will
too and that's you are the best
marketing we have so thank you all so
much for continuing to do that all right
Becca is up next in Orlando Becca how
are you
doing I'm good thank you thanks for
taking my call
sure what's going on I'm just checking
in um well last week my husband's um
bank account was garnished and um we
found you guys in the Ramsey Show after
trying to figure out what to do and
we're just wondering if bankruptcy is
our only option or how to proceed oh
gosh Becca what's the situation what's
going
on um well it was about eight years ago
that he had a car repossessed and that
was before we were together and he
didn't realize that there was further
action that needed to be taken at that
time um so then last week uh his we had
well we just were married a year ago and
we finally merged our bank accounts and
everything over so thankfully the
account that is garnished didn't have
anything in it because we combined
everything on my side so they tried to
drain an empty bank account correct so
we can still pay our bills because they
didn't garnish um our chair account
through a different bank
um but we don't have enough in savings
to um pay for the amount that we believe
is
ow okay how much is
owed um 9,000 $99,000 okay uh how much
you guys make how much do you guys make
a
year about
89,000 okay why do you feel like you
would be bankrupt I'm just curious why
that was part of your
question um well he reached out to I
think four different lawyers um and they
all said that that was our best option
and really didn't give us any other
option um neither of us even knew what
garnishment was so we're trying to soak
up as much information and that's why we
found you guys we're like let's just
listen to as many shows as we can um to
see if we can find the answer but um we
don't really know what our other option
would be um the lawyers seem to think
that since we were already garnished
that there's no way to um make like a
payment plan
or or anything like that have you
contacted this creditor who's garnishing
the bank
account uh yes he did okay what did they
say um it sounds like they just wanted
the full amount due um padly I wasn't on
the phone call but um my husband can't
be here today so it sounds like there's
a way out you pay the 9,000 you get it
in writing that this is paid in full and
this debt is
cleared right if we don't have we only
have six ,000 um dollars right now uh
would we need to pay it all at once
that's a question for them if they're
willing to settle for six and say hey
this was a all the money we have that
happened a decade ago
correct yes yes okay so they're happy to
get any money at this point yeah for
sure Becca yeah bankruptcy this is that
is that shouldn't even you don't even
need to say that anymore you guys are
far I'm shocked that these lawyers told
you to bankrupt for three grand this was
so stupid no I'm like you could sell
four TVs and a couch and get that money
if you needed it right I'm like that no
you're not going to be bankrupt over
three grand is there something else
going on that we don't know about like
are there other debts and things that
you haven't
mentioned um I mean we have like the
regular stuff on mortgage and um like
1,00 in credit card debt and my
husband's current car that he owns he
has payments left on that what's left on
the car
loan on the car loan uh the it's the
same amount in the 9,000 and then we
just bought um a small condo um right
after we got married so we have the
whole mortgage basically left on that
and how much is that
for uh 207 okay okay yeah well if I were
you guys I mean I would contact the
Creditor that has this and again it's a
10-year-old credit I mean like it
meaning it's been passed by creditor
after creditor and it's been sold and
it's here and there I mean it's been on
a journey for 10 years um so I if I were
you I would call and say I have six
grand I'll send you today and if not I
can get you the other three in the next
30 days or whatever it is but um I would
not give them any more access to any
accounts okay that is like number one
because they will they'll come in and
Garn they'll do exactly what they did um
but thankfully that was from an old
account to right is there a way to
prevent that that's what we I think we
were worried about communicating with
them more because yeah you just don't
give it to them no I would no they don't
need any access to any of your personal
stuff no so I I just would I just
wouldn't give it to them and they don't
need it so Becca like this this type of
situation just so you can picture it and
this isn't to down not to downplay these
people but this is some guy in a cubicle
who's been on the job for 90 days there
so and gets a gets a sheet of paper with
credits that have again these these old
debts that have been sold from one
company to the other to the I like this
this is these are not they sound like
scary people they're not scary people
okay you you can you can do this okay so
just don't don't give over and be like
oh my gosh you're if we're talking about
the IRS or something that's a different
story right but in this situation I just
I would not be I would not be concerned
Becca because you guys work hard you
make good money uh you can get this
cleaned up really quickly and if they
would settle for six Grands that's the
only option they have so that's what I
would tell them the only thing I can
give you right now is six grand that's
all I have I can do a payment plan over
the next 60 days to get you the other
three Grand but I don't have any more
money this is all I have will you settle
and if they say yes just like George
said get it in writing have them email
you get the name of the person you're
talking to get the number get the
extension get all record the calls do
everything do everything you can to have
proof that it has been settled if they
will and if they won't then just yeah
set up a plan for the next 60 days and
then Becca if I were you and your
husband and general regardless of this
um I would get I would I would work
extra I would do a budget I'd cut
everything I'd get this credit card paid
off get your car loan paid off and you
guys will be in a really great position
I mean you have a great condo it's worth
200 Grand which is very reasonable for
what you guys make and um you guys could
be on your way to something great but
you got to just change the way you have
been looking at money and that's one of
the biggest hurdles with this so if you
stay on the line Skyler will pick up and
I want to give you guys Financial Peace
University and every dollar premium
which is our budgeting app um just to
get you guys some of this like basic
knowledge since you're new to the show
because um we've found over three
decades Becca the the best way to to
live go through life with your money and
this will be the plan it's called the
baby steps so I'm I'm excited for you
guys to engage this but yeah do not um
at all feel like you are bankrupt that
you are hopeless this is the one of the
easiest Solutions Today George I feel
very hopeful about appr it so much
absolutely thanks for calling Becca and
have your husband watch this call to
give him some hope I I think what
Rachels people get they get spooked
there's these collectors calling them
and they're telling them and then the
lawyers are tell well you just got to go
bankrupt and when you look at the facts
on paper you're like we make $90,000 a
year we're bringing home $6,000 a month
can we come up with $33,000 if we really
tried yes yeah and so most side hustle
1,500 to two grand in just a side hustle
if you had to pick up Uber at night crap
around the house you can make a th000
bucks in a month right right exactly so
there's a lot of Hope here but a lot of
people call the show and their first
thing is I got to file bankruptcy and
it's those people usually like oh you're
fine yep and so that's what we do here
we want to give you guys hope but also
the reality that you can get out of this
but you know it's like going to the
dentist you're like my tooth hurts of
course he's going to want to fill the
cavity and you know make a little bit of
money and that's what happens when you
go to these some of these lawyers that
are you know there's some great apples
out there but there's some bad ones who
go Absolutely I'll help you file
bankruptcy just which also by the way
cost thousands of dollarss out of your
pocket to file bankruptcy it yeah yeah
it's not free lawyers want to get paid
yeah and the the garnishing I mean and
that would spook you too right if if you
realize oh my gosh this creditor has
access to a bank account which thank God
it didn't have any money in it but yeah
that's so violent like you know what I
mean that makes you feel like they are
scary thing yeah personal privacy there
it is it's weird oh oh gosh I'm glad you
called Becca I hope that gave you some
some peace and a plan that you guys yeah
you're going to be able to do this we're
excited for you that puts this hour of
the Ramsay show in the books thanks to
my co-host Rachel Cruz to Skyler to will
to James Andrew Zach they made it happen
this hour the the world doubted them but
they they they came through for you guys
keeping the show on the air and we thank
you so much for listening and watching
we'll be back before you know
[Music]
it
n
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George camel joined by
Rachel Cruz host of The Rachel crw show
and co-host of mine on Smart money happy
hour this is your show America give us a
call atle 8825
5225 we'll talk about your life and your
money Chad is up first in Green Bay
Wisconsin Chad what's going
on hey George and Rachel good to talk to
you I'm uh liking the show it's a great
show wonderful show thank you thank you
yeah and so I'm kind of a first time I
would say not first time listener but
just started kind of following the ramsy
way here and just caught bits and pieces
of some of your shows and I really wish
I would have found this these Rec
resources years and years ago but I've
always been pretty good with money but
um now we're kind of in a predicament my
wife and I were expecting our sixth
child actually coming on Monday wow Chad
you can give uh give George some uh I'm
exhausted one man you guys are Trippers
you get like a Nobel Peace Prize I think
at that point yeah exactly we do our do
our best it's a crazy house but we
really enjoy it that's awesome and we're
blessed the bigger family the better
they say so I love that
great what's your predicament
here um so yeah um so my wife is a
inhome daycare provider and with the
baby coming she's going to be out of
work or you know taking a step back from
work um which is fine um we have funds
in place to kind of prepare for that but
we are going to be tapping into our
emergency funds and um our bank account
even before this fluctuated a lot
sometimes $2,000 down a month sometimes
up a thousand so I think an big issue
that I'm finding out is we really need
to be on a budget obviously and figure
out where this money is going we try to
budget a few times and we've always
fallen off the horse um we get triggered
by it it's hard to track every dollar
and be nitpicky with each other and it
just triggers our stress and um you know
and then affects marital relationship if
you're always on each other's case so or
I'm the one in charge of the money
mainly so it's it's kind of hard that
way but you end up being the the bad guy
in a sense looking at all the details
and saying yes we can't spend X Y and Z
you become the no the no spouse
almost right wow so but she's been good
lately and I she's on track now on board
now I should say and yeah she's a she's
a wonderful woman I'm glad to have her
yeah how much how much you guys make a
year um pretty much solely on my income
80 plus she
makes 1,500 a month so I I could just
tell you my net take home per month if
that yeah that's right that'll be your
new income once she's not working
correct okay yep and that's 3,800 a
month net okay what are your
expenses our expenses is are around
2,300 a month that's not counting
groceries and miscellaneous okay bills
bills expenses is that does that include
debt that 2,300 or their payments Within
that we have no debt than house loan yep
okay so that includes your mortgage that
2,300 and utilities and all of that
correct correct okay um and then yeah
and then you have 1500 left but that
doesn't include food and miscellaneous
stuff like you were saying imagine with
six kids plus you guys that's a lot of
food yeah it's that's probably the
hardest part of your whole budget is
trying to nail that down exactly yep I
budgeted like 685 for it and uh yeah
we're right around there totally that
sounds very reasonable yeah I mean I
think it's one of those things Chad I
think you'all will be in a season um
especially with her not working yeah
that you're you're going to probably
feel a level of a pinch but it what a
weird thing with a budget in the way we
always try to frame it and as you kind
of start to live on it and it becomes
part of your rhythm is that it actually
gives you more peace because you
actually have control over it so even if
it's you know $600 left over after food
for miscellaneous to be able to really
say okay for this month where can the
600 go and you guys both together like
you were saying agree on it know where
it's going and then the next month right
like maybe there's no clothes we don't
buy clothes for this coming month but
next next month yeah let's put let's put
150 towards some clothes and we're not
going to do something else that we did
in February but we'll do in March right
so you kind of just month-to Monon gauge
that and then obviously I mean I mean
there there's no debt which is which is
awesome and you guys have an emergency
fund so if something does come up with
the baby or something that you need the
money it's there because how much how
much is in that we had the $1,000
emergency fund plus um we had about 4 to
five months worth of um step three of
the
expenses yeah that's great so yeah I
would do everything in my power which is
really hard with six kids so I know this
is much easier said than done on the
side of the call um just to try not to
tap into that that emergency fund if you
need it it's there right that's that's
to help relieve uh if something does
come up and you need cash instead of
going into the debt for it you obviously
have that cash to use um but you can
start to practice both of you guys
together to run this
household on and it is a tight budget
like that that that is what it is but
there is something about having the
power and saying okay this is where we
know what going and not feeling like
gosh I feel like we're just running and
we're not getting anywhere at least you
have numbers on paper that show you yeah
you are you're are getting somewhere and
and you guys are you know you're doing a
great job you really are how have you
been budgeting currently
Chad oh we have not been okay so this is
just kind of napkin math you know your
income and you know roughly what your
bill is that up to yep and exactly and I
look at bank accounts add it up track it
monthly see our see where we're going up
down up down that's a lot of that's a
lot of brain calories and stress so
here's what I'll do I'll gift you every
dollar premium and that's going to help
your wife she can log in on her phone
you can be logged on your phone to the
same account you guys both have
accountability and transparency and
bring her into it not in a negative way
but hey help me adjust this let's
include a little bit of fund money for
her so she doesn't see this budget as
this negative thing holding her back
adding stress to her life instead it's
oh look we have this much left to spend
on food for the week let's me meal plan
together let's figure out how we're
going to do this and so you not just
being in charge of the finances but
bringing her into it and her getting a
vote and both of you having that
accountability yeah and I mean in Chad
in a perfect world you know what's great
about every dollar premium is it
attaches to your bank account so your
transactions when you swipe your debit
card come in so if you guys shop at
Costco a Costco transaction will hit
every dollar budget and you drag it up
to the groceries or the Costco line item
however you guys do it and you know a
good Rhythm to keep this to keep the
money I don't know I feel like some
couples it's a very like formal way of
dealing with money and they sit down
every month W night we text I mean it's
probably every other day about something
going on of like oh hey there was this
transaction what vinmo is this what's
going on here okay there's that uh we
didn't have we had less in this category
should we we're going to move it down
like we just kind of it's a it's kind of
this ongoing conversation because money
is a reflection of our life right and so
um you're going to see that it just
becomes a rhythm for you guys and it's a
good goal to hit it's one of those
things that you map out for the month
and you say okay this is our goal to hit
and it's it may take on um you know some
new habits and it may take a little
while to get some of those habits in
place but I I really you guys sound so
grounded and just I don't know I have a
lot a lot of faith in you guys Chad so
hold on the line Sky will pick up uh for
our baby gift to you and your wife every
doar and I'll throw in my new kids book
I'm glad for what I have for the baby
for that's really cute for all the kids
too but
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsy show I'm
George camel joined by Rachel Cruz this
hour the number to call is
5225 Rachel I wanted to Spring this on
you I've got an article here from Yahoo
here's the headline prepare your heart
my family of four can no longer live
comfortably on
$230,000 a year how much here's how much
the American dream really costs I want
to get your take on this you ready for
it man yes former Goldman Sachs analyst
says his family of four need to earn
more than 230k per year in order to live
comfortably in the Bay Area okay well
Bay Area we'll we'll Aster that's one of
the most expensive places to live in
America okay here we go so Sam Doan Now
46 this he hit headlines in 2012 he
retired at 34 you know the fire movement
all of that he had a $3 million net
worth oh wow okay well since that time
he's a father of two he's been living
off of passive income from stocks bonds
and real estate okay sounds good right
the financial Guru now says his
investments will generate just 230,000
before tax while his annual expenses are
projected to top 288,000 in 2024 my gosh
so he says to net that sum of money he
needs to earn
$420,000 before taxes in order to make
his life work so he says he's declaring
he's not asking for sympathy or empathy
he's admitting they have an upper middle
class lifestyle with his wife and two
kids yeah yeah I would think so and he
says there's areas to cut but overall
it's a realistic and comfortable
Lifestyle the annual budget includes
Rachel over $80,000 for private school
tuition sure and $24,000 for healthc
care costs he also estimates food
expenses will Top
$26,000 this year and his housing
expenses 6,000 yeah and then housing
expenses which includes property taxes
maintenance insurances are estimated at
a whopping
$68,000 so because he says my wife and I
don't have normal day jobs we have to
pay for unsubsidized Healthcare which
cost $2,300 a month in premium which
would be fair right like if you have to
do you don't have it through your
employer it's not subsidized it's
expensive it's crazy expensive so um you
know he he just goes on to say the
budget breakdown is sure to alarm
Americans who are struggling to cope
with soaring cost of utilities rent
groceries it's a struggle to raise a
family in an expensive city safer
retirement figure out how to spend a lot
of time with your kids before they leave
for college and enjoy life in general
that's that was kind of his last quote
there so do you feel for this
guy I had a feeling that you would be
our you know what someone with some
empathy and sympathy for this situation
While most Americans would be like wow W
you live in the Bay Area making2 200
plus thousand oh I'm like a family
making 90 right now is pissed at him
they're just like are you kidding me are
you kidding me so here's the deal what
they've considered normal is this
lifestyle right that that it is normal
to I mean they're they're they're almost
2100 a month on food which means you are
out to eat at great restaurants oh
they're eating good they're eating good
have you been to arwan no it's this it
makes Whole Foods look cheap it's it's
in California okay so yeah it's
frightening yeah so I'm like the the
problem with that is it is um everything
is just I was going to say inflated
inflation inflated um in what the norm
is for them right it's just here it's
here and if that's the life they want to
live we're not mad at that but don't say
that the average family has to live that
because there's people that are living a
sacrificial lifestyle right now to
better their families that are
significantly their Norm is down here so
the complaining at somebody that's
living up here is what is what bugs me
yeah well well in this idea that you
have to well I want to live in the Bay
Area I should get to live wherever I
want to live well that comes at a cost
yeah and we're seeing some of the cost
here and by the way you chose I know you
want to put your kids in private school
but it's a choice to put your kids in
private school that choice comes with a
cost in his example
$80,000 a year for two kids for two kids
so it's it's a $40,000 school you know
which again private schools even here in
Nashville you know yep can can get up
there and I don't want to work a
additional 9 to5 working for the man he
works for himself great that also comes
with a cost you have to pay for
unsubsidized Healthcare which we could
get in a whole tangent about how that
whole system is messed up but I don't
feel I want to feel bad CH that you're
making that's that's it that you can
make different choices and have a
different outcome and that can be
choices from where you shop for your
groceries to your job right or to where
you're living so I mean that those are
choices you're making and this is the
outcome that you're getting so to get a
different outcome you have to make
different choices and if I'm going to
live in a super these are ultra high
cost of living areas yes and so yeah you
need to Miami you got to make half a
million dollars a year in order to be
comfortable New York Manhattan you know
like yeah so so the F that is one thing
with the fire movement that we always
kind of push back against he thought
this 3 million would float him he's
realizing it's not enough to cover my
expenses and that's that's the fear and
this idea of like I'm going to live on
nothing and invest everything which in a
sense you're like okay there's some like
great principles in that idea of living
of living on less than you make yeah of
of we're not going to give in instant
gratification we're going to delay
everything live on nothing and we're
going to be okay so that I can not work
and live off these Investments but the
prediction of what you're actually going
to want to how you're going to want to
live is going to probably up that's what
I've always said to myself I'm like
65-year old Rachel is going to be way
bougier than 35y old Rachel so I'm like
you're it is you're you're going to
upgrade your life as life goes on and so
that's the fire movement caution have
and there's some lifestyle creep here
too as well we can admit you know he
said we're living an upper middle class
life we live comfortably we do all the
things that we want to do there's not a
lot of sacrifice happening with this and
uh you know he did well he's still young
and multi-millionaire so not can't
complain too much compared to the
average American but uh I'm I'm not
going to vote for sympathy on this one
Rachel you can go M oh no I can't either
okay thank you for that I can't all
right back to reality Michelle is in
Sand Point Idaho Michelle what's going
on hey George and
Rachel my family got turned on to the
ram Z program about three months ago and
so that me we're all working um through
the dead Snowball right now and we don't
have very many point
hey Michelle speak directly in your
phone for me you're breaking
up okay um is that any clear George it's
still it's still a little rocky we may
get you on hold to get your phone clear
if we can't clean it up but all I heard
was you guys are in you're trying to pay
off debt in baby step
2 yes we're in baby step to okay and we
don't have anything except car insurance
right now in our monthly budget okay and
so I've been looking over getting quotes
for the different ones
and I'm just not sure you know basically
we have where in our monthly budget 42%
of our is the ratio of our income our
9,000 a month household between the four
of us um then that's going to paying our
debts in baby step two okay and so your
question is what What other insurance
you
need which one to budget for first
because I know that if we took all our
extra that's on the snowball right now
and used it for insurance that until we
get our shovel bigger in the next couple
months we wouldn't be making any
traction and uh I'm not currently don't
think I can sell that pitch well
insurance is not a b insurance is a
these are non-negotiable it's almost
under your utilities is kind of what you
could say and the problem right now is
if forgo Insurance it could derail you
financially in the biggest way it could
cause bankruptcy if you don't have
health insurance and you get some
medical bills it can be game over if you
don't have homeowners insurance and
renters insurance and something happens
it's game
over yeah so so yeah insurance is it's
it's above your debt in that sense it's
a it's a necessary expense that we all
that you will pay so you'll so anything
after insurance and utilities and
mortgage or rent food all of that
whatever is left there then take that
amount for your debt
snowball okay and this uh we just got
access thankfully one of our family
works for Costco to Smart dollar and so
I know that the financial piece
university lessons are in there is that
right yes go watch the insurance lesson
for sure but here's the here's the ones
you definitely need Auto you have that
you need health insurance you need term
life insurance and you need homeowners
or renters insurance that's the Bare
Bones and we'll walk you through the
rest of those in Financial Peace
University thanks so much for the call
this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
this is the ramsy show I'm George camel
joined by Rachel Cruz open phones at
88255 225 Evan is in Toledo up next Evan
how are you
doing doing well George how about
yourself we're doing great how can we
help today yeah first I wanted to say
glad to finally talk to you you've been
all over my Tik Tok love your messaging
the algorithm knows what Evan
needs is working
man thank you for calling instead of
dming being like hey bro I need
financial advice I call the show guys
thank you right yeah of course so my
question is um I'm putting way too much
money into my beater car um should I use
my emergency fund to purchase a new
one walk us through what way too much
money is so how much is the car worth
and how much are you putting into it
yeah so um the car is worth the Kelly
Blue Book is between four and six um
it's a 2010 Honda Accord I purchased it
20 months ago um for
$9,700 and I have unfortunately put over
the course of those 20 months uh
$1,624
67 uh but who's coming goodness gracious
what what did it need were there major
issues that you didn't catch in the
inspection or what so that's part of the
problem too um I I rushed myself into
purchasing this vehicle um did not do
proper due diligence um I I did the
Carfax sent it to a few people that know
things about cars um but went up there
you know drove two hours went with my
brother who him and I combined no zero
about vehicles um and I mean I drove it
it didn't I mean I knew there was going
to be some work but I figured it's a
Honda it's only got 106,000 miles on it
sure time you know when I was purchasing
it I'll be able to do a little bit of
work and then ride this thing until uh
you know the wheels fall off and um
right off the rip the turn the tuneup
with a bunch of stuff um the radiator
went out um the first expense I had was
$500 I forget what all went into that I
don't have the best spreadsheet in front
of me um in terms of what work was done
but it felt like it got to a certain
point where I was putting enough in I'm
like okay I can just ride this thing out
but it seems like every two or three
months something happens I mean last
February was the starter um I just had
my crank sensor go out during the cold
um last week and my fear is with my all
my side hustles require me to drive yeah
you need more of a reliable vehicle and
I think you've driven it EV to the
ground I like the idea that you drive it
to the wheels fall off I mean it's
gotten to that point basically well the
wheel literally did fall off I had my
ball joint fail um luckily I was in an
Aldi parking lot and not um you know and
not going on a high speed on the highway
I guess you know for other people to
learn and even myself I just don't want
anyone else to feel the way I have
emotionally you know driving a 2 $2,000
2010 Honda Accord isn't I mean it I mean
I own it you know I don't owe anybody
money on it it feels great being able to
say that but you know at some point I
feel like I've gota cut things loose
right how much money do you have right
now um I have in liquid cash uh
$22,000 great good for you any
debt no debt way to go man yes I would
for sure get a new car so let's say you
can you sell at private party for six to
get top
dollar the guy that um has been working
on it for me I'm sure we could maybe
find somebody my my I try to be a little
more conservative I could probably get
four cash for it easy well is everything
fixed on it now or does it still need
more
work the check engine light is on but
that's the story of a lot of people I'm
sure and I think it's just the
aftermarket um oxygen sensor the um I
the catalytic converter that's the only
thing the reason that's that's flashing
so it's got brand new tires you know a
lot of stuff basically well maybe you
take the you if you can sell for five
you take 10 from your savings and you go
buy a $155,000 car what's your income
yeah um I think with everything and when
you take into account my side hustles
and everything I probably net 70,000 a
year great yeah that's awesome that's a
reasonable purchase and you can drive
that $155,000 car for a while do you
have any other future goals like a home
down payment are you investing right
now yeah I'm investing a lot so over the
course of the last three years I put a
bunch of money into a non-retirement
tied like investment account and just
been riding dividends um in that space I
mean that account I think is
$55,000 and I'd rather leave it where
it's at um I mean I'm putting enough
into my 401k I'm maxing out my Roth um
good and actively you know investing
that I mean I feel like I'm in a good
spot yeah you are in a great spot yes so
just replenish the emergency fund once
you buy the car make sure you're at you
know three to six months of expenses in
there but other than that dude you're
doing all the right
things yeah it's like and I know the
concept was great right you know buy
used reliable and just a little bit of
the due diligence was that's going to
say I I think for people out there
because I think you're right there's so
many lessons always to learn on this
journey and one of them yes is to always
do the inspection and to your point we
laughed at at another call caller or not
at another caller with another call a
few weeks ago uh because I was having
trouble keeping up with all the car
lingo and whoever I was co-hosting with
they're like you just need a car person
in your life whether it's the uncle or
the friend but like there's always that
person in your life that just knows cars
and just take advantage of their
knowledge right and because you are
going to be buying a crappier car when
you're especially when you're getting
out of debt and you're doing this plan
and you sell the nice new car that has a
$900 car payment every month to it you
know we say go get a beater it's this
kind of thing but you want to be wise
that to your point and those beaters are
not there to last you 3 four years down
the road maybe get you through 9 to 12
months and then maybe you upgrade a
little bit there right so it is a
continual change it's not something
that'll be forever so I think you're at
the point for sure Evan that yeah you
can definitely definitely Step Up Next
Car you will definitely do a pre-
purchase inspection I guarantee it yes
you would and and I would really
challenge you to try to get closer to
that six because you've put money into
it it's not just a crappy you know 2010
card like it has new tire like you put
value into it and I want you to be able
to get that out of it so don't don't
just settle and if you look at you know
what these cars are actually going for
in the open market even over 100,000
miles even a 2010 Accord you could get
over $10,000 if if you can get this
thing in good
shape it's a wild time you may have
gotten a lemon too it's kind of what it
sounds like yeah I did and it was tough
because I went across state lines and I
didn't read all of the paperwork and I'm
sure I signed away my lemon law rights
they're different in Michigan than they
are in Ohio and um it took it took 25
days for me to get it into the shop
anyway originally so it kind of was a
worst case scenario totally and you have
a good reputable honest mechanic that
you're working
with yeah he's a great guy okay um you
know and it's uh he's a retired Honda
certified um you know mechanic just does
work out of his garage um I have no
reason not to trust him um yeah and for
you Evan to to keep I feel like there's
so much good stuff for listeners out
there with the story and that's another
thing is you're as car maintenance as
Evan has felt over the last two years it
just it gets expensive right and so I do
think though for people listening get a
second opinion because sometimes that
one person not saying your guy Evan is
this but there are some people that
they're like oh my gosh it's kind of
like I don't know you go somewhere and
they're like oh well this this this and
this and if it's me again that doesn't
know cars I'm like okay fix all it
happens at the dentist like you need
$3,000 worth of work the other dentist
is like no you're fine we'll fill that
one tooth you're good for a while you
know like all right cool y so second
opinion on big maintenance things uh for
those of you listening
to yeah and we to give you a little
insight to to my driving habits I mean
in the 20 months with all that work I've
done I still put 30,000 miles on the
vehicle um yeah so that's a to me that's
a lot of driving oh yeah that's a lot of
driving for sure and and my opinion
looking in that 2019 probably 2020 Civic
range I know those might be a little bit
more expensive I know the the body style
got bigger but in my mind that's
something that is going to be reliable
even if I get it you know pre-owned
certified sure um and that's something
where I just kind of eat the cash and
then spend the next few months
rebuilding that emergency fund yep for
sure yep just be paying cash for the car
don't let it be a crazy percentage but
it's not you're doing great Evan just
overall your overall cial picture is
awes you got the right head space around
this don't let this hinder you from
buying another used car and don't let
that hinder you America don't just go
out buying a new car because you heard
Evan's story okay make the right choice
get the pre- purchase inspection it's
like 150 bucks you'll have a lot of
Peace of Mind worth it this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
all our scripture of the day Matthew
5:15 no one lights a lamp and then puts
it under a basket instead a lamp is
placed on a stand where it gives light
to everyone in the house Mary K Ash said
those who are blessed with the most
Talent don't necessarily outperform
everyone else it's the people with
follow through that Excel that's a good
quote and Rachel that's not Mary Kate
and Ashley it's Mary Kate Ash a
different historical figure no I didn't
want to confuse you thank you solving a
mystery before dinner time man I used to
love those books man Adventures of Mary
Kate and Ashley How the West Was Fun
anyone oh all of it throwback there you
go the Holiday in the Sun was the
pre-teen big movie where they went to
Atlantis remember Atlantis the resort
like right when it open they filmed um
what great and the enemy on it was uh
Megan Fox wow back in the day I know
fact in the pre-teen take Rachel to your
Mary Kate and Ashley trivia night she
will crush it oh well back to what we're
here to do Rachel is answer America's
questions and help them solve their
life's problems and uh hopefully we can
do that with Jeremy in Palm Springs
Jeremy what's going on hi George how you
doing doing great how can we help I got
$75,000 in debt and uh B be on the way
congratulations one bad thing one good
thing thanks to watch what number of
child is this for you Jeremy it's it's
our first oh congratulations when are
when are youall due thank you uh due in
about a month and a halfish okay five
six weeks out huh yeah that's exciting
coming up quick so you paired those two
things together it tells me that you're
a little bit stressed about this debt
you want to try to get out of as much of
it as possible before baby's here or
what yes yeah well that's that's the
instincts uh me and my wife decided to
go ahead and just put everything in
savings because we don't know how to
raise a kid yet that's wise so how much
it's going to cost and all that so um
yeah you're doing the right thing look
for some guidance so I don't know how
long you've been listening to the show
but you guys are in baby step two where
you're paying off all Consumer Debt
using the debt snowball method yes and
because you're having a baby we call
this stor mode which means we are
pausing the baby steps we're pausing
debt payoff and we're stacking up cash
and savings until mom and baby are home
safe because don't want to go yeah
staying current on your bills yes good
call um but yes but so okay so how much
will you have Jeremy stack stashed away
here in the next month or two and what
you guys have been saving so far well so
far uh it's it's kind of complicated but
um right now we have about
33,000 in emergency fund okay that's
great um and that will that will go up
in the next uh couple months hopefully
to what what do you think that'll be
uh if I were to guess maybe it all
depends on uh job and and all that yeah
so maybe about
35,000 okay perfect in the next few
months so let's say you have 35k baby's
here mom and baby are home safe then we
can take most of that and throw it at
this 75 in
debt knocking it almost in half
right yes I guess my question is is um
there's about 50 5 of that in school
loans and they range from like 3% to to
7% and there's like it's like one loan
but it's got 10 loans yeah they're
broken out into separate little
loans yeah so should I attack that as
one loan as like the 7% or should I
attack the car loan at 3% what's the car
loan what's left on that the car loan is
at 22,000 right now okay and is that all
of the debt the 5K and the
22k uh yes minus the the house debt yeah
sure okay so with the debt snowball
what's beautiful about it is you don't
have to worry about the interest you are
trying to focus on momentum and progress
so you're going to lay out those debts
from smallest to largest so let's say
one student loan is a th000 the next one
is 3,000 the next one's 5,000 then you
would just knock those out one by one
from smallest to largest while making
minimum payments on the rest and what
that does is you free up a payment
sooner you apply that payment plus all
the margin you were throwing at the next
debt and the same thing happens and you
can see how the snowball picks up Snow
and most people following this plan they
get rid of their debt in 18 to 24 months
using this method okay how much do you
make a year
okay um well that's in transition right
now I just uh just got out of the
military so hopefully going back to
making about uh 70 80,000 a year great
what's the car
worth the car uh honly haven't looked it
up it's a 2019 it's pretty new pretty
new car for for us anyway okay I'm just
wondering if if you got to the point
where you're like man I have 77,000 in
debt I'm going to make 70 this year this
is going to take four years at this rate
it's a possibility that you end up
selling the car and downsizing with
cash yeah so that's something to think
about just to speed up this process for
you guys because you got you got a solid
income but you also have some pretty
serious debt here
yeah y so if your income's not going to
go up significantly over the next year
you may want to look at just selling
that car while while you can while you
can still get some good money for it and
then using some of that cash and savings
to get a beater car to get you by for a
year gotcha okay yeah that's an option
man thank you so much for the call and
congrats on the baby that's exciting
with the new edition woo I'm uh I'm five
months ahead of him here with a
five-month old and it's it's a wild ride
Jeremy no one can prepare you not even
Rachel Cruz and she tried emotionally
tried to give you all the baselines
George what can I say you and Winnie are
great y' are killing she's the best mom
killing it you know we were at dinner
the other night and we were just trying
to be have a moment of connection and we
were I said what are three things you're
learning this is what we do on date
nights you Winston do that too right
great good question and she said I'm
learning that I'm a good mom and I was
like yes 1,000% yes that is so good and
I feel for moms out there did the mom
give guilt is real it's just like
constant chaos and emotions and lack of
sleep and should I work should I stay I
feel for new parents out there you see
mom's like take care of yourself and
you're like yes I will don't worry about
the laundry but you're like okay the
worst advice Rachel I'm going to say
this this is the worst advice I got when
it came to Parenting and I heard it from
so many people oh no did I give this to
you nap when the baby oh no I hate that
yeah don't do that what when am I going
to shower when am I going to eat a meal
when am I going to do laundry that's a
silly that's a silly one that's really
nice now at night obviously sure ideal
that's fair let's get the baby sleeping
then we can all sleep but yeah no that's
a yeah well Rachel meet Rachel she's up
next to finish off this hour in
Scottdale Rachel get right to it we're
up against the
clock hi um I'm Rachel I live in Scott
I'm currently working as a nurse and I
was wondering if I should take out some
student loans for my bachelor's and
nursing oo how much is it going to cost
yeah
um well I was looking at some programs
the cheapest program I could look at was
40 Grand and that's kind of a lot for me
I don't really have any debt right now
and the big thing is like as an I work
as a nurse currently with my associates
and I make like there's really no
difference between the bachelors and
Associates at the moment just because um
as far as your salary shortage yeah
exactly so so the ROI isn't there you're
not going to be making 40 Grand
more 20 grand exactly yeah so you want
to do it then and why
now um well what everyone
does well that and at the moment I'm
really able to get most jobs I want but
I don't know if that's going to last
long term only because a lot of nurses
were scared off because of covid yeah
and I think eventually we're gonna we're
the nurses coming in it will be caught
back up and everything will be okay and
I I fear that I won't be able to get the
jobs I want later down the line that's
my fear yeah and I think that's a valid
fear but I don't think that's a valid
reason to take on debts to prevent
something that hasn't even happened yet
you know so when the time comes and you
start to see that shift start to happen
then I would say okay let's think about
hey what would it look like to go back
to school pay cash for it though because
we'll never um at least on this show
advise you to go into debt um how
quickly could you save that up that 40
Grand
um well I'm married me and my husband
together make about 90 grand a year but
cost of living in Scott's pretty high
like we're in a one bedroom and it's
2100 so I mean it would take a while
totally it would take a while yeah I
mean I think it could be a good goal for
you Rachel here in the next you know
four or five years and just put some
money aside in a sinking fund and just
say hey that's kind of my school fund
and then you may look up in four years
and the and the thing you fear has not
come to fruition and then you make a
different decision maybe you guys have a
baby and life looks different I mean who
knows what's going to happen but I would
not rush into a degree and go into debt
for it on something that's not reality
yet retweet that puts this hour of the
Ramsay show in the
[Music]
books
yeah